le chesnay et rocquencourt sont
officiellement mariés après plusieurs
mois de délibérations les deux communes
ont officiellement fusionné lors d'un
conseil d'installation programmée ce
mercredi 2 janvier au ces mais la fusion
est taillé un acte d'avenir un acteur
un acte logique dans la mesure où l'un
fusion permettra de réaliser des choses
que nous ne tuons pas en mesure de faire
jusqu'à présent de réaliser des
économies d'échelle et puis de gouverner
avec beaucoup plus de d'aisance et de
facilité de rendre un maximum de
services à la population
lors de ce conseil dix sept adjoints ont
été nommés jean-françois peuvrier ancien
maire d'euros concours a notamment été
désigné premier adjoint de la ville pour
le poste de maire l'ancien élu du chéné
philippe brillault seul candidat prend
la tête de cette nouvelle commune
baptisée le chine et rocquencourt
il a obtenu 48 voix sur 57 après un vote
à bulletin secret moi c'est la première
fois que je suis amené à gérer une
commune toute nouvelle qui a que
quelques heures
donc cela nous a appris avec
l'administration
beaucoup de choses beaucoup de l'égalité
et beaucoup de réinitialisation de la
commune en bref une bonne remise en
cause de tout le monde ça fait du bien
et ça va rebooster nos deux communes
prochaine étape pour la vie nouvelle du
chéné rocancourt définir le nom de ses
33 mille habitants la décision devrait
être prise à la fin du mois de janvier
lors d'un prochain conseil municipal